so this is interesting a lot of my
friends have been pushing me to watch
the game of Thrones we have some Game of
Thrones fans here yeah I love boobs -
boobs boobs and swords mystery I get it
it's obviously a great show I don't
watch it but here's why it's not because
of the show it's cuz of me it's my fault
the show is too big too much and this
too small no room I can't fit it all in
there I don't have the RAM right now you
understand it's a big undertaking to
start watching a new TV show cuz you're
not just watching it you're building a
new relationship with it does that make
sense it's like a girlfriend
she's the main character but then there
are all the supporting characters her
favorite locations were multiple
complicated storylines and you're
expected to remember all of it she gets
mad like how can you not remember my
friend Rebecca from that one scene in
season 1
I guess tonight's episode won't have
nudity or adult themes too much is
expected with today's television Game of
Thrones it was a lot got a study maps
got to be familiar with a whole slew of
spells multiple listen multiple kingdoms
kingdoms as in plural as in way too many
I can't even find my way around
Massachusetts and I'm from there
I need a GPS to drive from my grammar
school to my childhood home but you want
me to remember where Castle blood is in
relation to Ice crest can't do it
Dinklage
not his campus named him like Peter
Dinklage's homing hey I always have a
hard time watching the wire to one of my
favorite shows the wire but I had a hard
time with it
you know why how many characters are on
that show three four hundred sometimes I
didn't even know who they were until
they got killed finally I'd put it
together be like Oh a cop shot that guy
so he's got he's like a bad one he was a
bad he's a bad guy but wait a cop shot
that other cop ah every city I can't
handle it I can only retain the
information for two shows at a time two
and a half tops right now between true
detective and Mad Men I got like four
thousand fake people in my mental
rolodex four thousand that means the
fake people are far outweighing the real
people in fact I'll erase real people
just to make room for whoever Draper's
boning and guy I sometimes get relieved
if somebody dies like when somebody
would get murdered on like Breaking Bad
I'd be relieved
I'd be like looks like I do have room to
remember the name of my barista it's the
same thing with movies too Harry Potter
too big too much what do I work for you
if you can watch the Harry Potter films
and actually remember the who the what
the where of the Voldemort's how why and
whatever congratulations you're a
lunatic wanna write
when I watch Harry Potter I'm completely
out of my depth I have to diagram what's
happening on my wall like I'm the guy
from a beautiful mind
I got pieces of string from one picture
to another connecting Ron Weasley to
Neville Longbottom I think I'm starting
to get this children's literature Lord
of the Rings - I love it but it's a bit
much
hobbits goblins orcs elves dwarves you
lost me they all got the same years
they're the same thing to me I feel like
sometimes I need an assistant like the
president at a cocktail party
you know I mean next to me like this is
Frodo Baggins he's from the Shire yes
sir he's the one who threw the ring of
into the fire of Mount Doom and then and
he comes up I can be like shadow good to
see ya how was the journey the Mount
Doom
Luthor was that what I'm saying is
entertainment used to be simple it used
to be like The Cosby Show from The Cosby
Show that was easy
The Cosby Show sure case you're
unfamiliar I'll catch you up to speed
and a brief moment there's a show about
a bunch of Cosby's starring Bill Cosby
called The Cosby Show that's it you get
it you could watch any episode and be
right on board same with cheers you
could jump into cheers at any point and
know immediately what was going on just
like ah okay as a bar there's a
good-looking guy there's a fat guy a
dumb guy and a mailman let's do this